buonasera buonasera allora un tè dic
sulla memoria e io invece questa sera
leggerò questo pomeriggio leggero perché
nonostante sia un attore con la memoria
degli osci lavori però ho tredici minuti
per raccontarvi tutto quello che io
penso sulla memoria
quindi siccome sono un po logorroico ho
bisogno di avere qualcosa che mi riporti
lì dove devo essere altrimenti poi mi
perdo però appunto per me la memoria è
una cosa importante perché altrimenti
non potrei fare il mio lavoro porto in
questo momento sette spettacoli in
cartellone in giro tutti a memoria e
quindi con la memoria io ho una
confidenza quotidiana e quindi la
memoria per ricordare scusa era così ho
tredici minuti per raccontarvi tutto
quello che io l'ho detto prima già
questo l'ho detto prima si allora era
così ho tredici minuti per raccontarvi
tutto quello che io penso sulla memoria
perché appunto solo un po logorroico e
quindi non a volte mi perdo nelle cose
che dico faccia delle deviazioni del
discorso invece io devo stare in 13
minuti che stanno per diventare 12
intanto li vedete anche voi no non
vogliono li vedete ma io vedo che stanno
per diventare 12 però ho dodici minuti
per ricordarmi tutto quello che scusate
si era era così che io ho 13 12 minuti
per raccontarvi tutto quello che devo
dire sulla questo pure l'ho già detto
prima si che sono logorroico l'ho detto
sì lo devo detto anche quello allora 13
minuti adesso 12 per raccontare tutto
quello che devo dire sulla memoria e
sono un po un logorroico quindi ho
bisogno di leggere e allora facciamo una
cosa consolidiamo questo fatto che ho
tredici minuti e che sono logorroico e
che voglio parlare di memoria ben
consolidato questo no non mi fate mi
fate mi fate mi fate perdere il tempo
poi non torna più niente allora e
consolidiamo queste tre nozioni che
diventano un ricordo lo ricordiamo tutti
adesso lo so anche io lo mettiamo di qua
e questo è
il mio passato adesso ho un passato sul
quale io posso andare avanti sì signore
perché vi devo raccontare appunto tutto
ciò che io penso della memoria ora
voglio andare avanti voglio comunicare
con voi noi qui stiamo comunicando no io
non vi vedo benissimo però vedo sento
che ci sono delle facce attente voi
state guardando mesto ad usando gli
occhi per guardarmi le orecchie per
ascoltare io uso la bocca per parlare le
mani ci guardiamoci annusiamo annusiamo
perché esistiamo
stiamo sentendo i ferormoni cioè quelli
ci dicono se ci piacciamo no se vi sta
interessando quello che vi dico se se a
voi do fastidio se volete che io finisca
presto me ne vada insomma stiamo usando
tutti i cinque sensi sto guardando anche
tutti quelli che invece in questo
momento stanno scrivendo sul cellulare
loro diciamo che non stanno esattamente
comunicando perché al massimo stanno
usando un solo senso per ascoltare
mentre intanto guardano con gli occhi
quello che li stanno scrivendo chissà
chi e su che sa chissà quale argomento
stanno usando le mani per rispondere in
bocca avranno per il gusto non lo so una
caramella che hanno buttato dentro prima
di entrare qui in teatro e con l'olfatto
sono impegnati a causa delle scarpe
perché non hanno fatto in tempo a
lavarsi erano in ritardo per il tè dice
sono arrivati alle scarpe fanno un odore
che impegna l'olfatto quindi diciamo che
è il migliore dei casi stanno usando un
solo senso per comunicare e invece e non
come dire noi invece comunichiamo con
tutti i cinque sensi un attore questo lo
sa e importante e fondamentale lavorare
sui cinque sensi per poter comunicare
siamo corpi che interagiscono ci stiamo
appunto guardandolo usando ci stiamo
ascoltando e per poter fare questo
dobbiamo coinvolgere tutto il nostro
essere e poter poi su questo avere un
ricordo di questo incontro fra non lo so
fra dieci giorni fra una settimana fra
un mese ci ricorderemo di questo essersi
guardati questo esserci annusati questo
esserci ascoltati poi che siano
piacevoli questi tredici minuti non
importa però avremo un ricordo c'è anche
quello starà qui nel passato e su quello
noi possiamo comunque andare avanti o
questa per me è la
comunicazione un attore lo sa benissimo
il corpo i sensi comunicano in maniera
molto più potente che le parole
soprattutto in maniera molto più vera
perché i sensi il corpo non mentono
non possiamo mentire col corpo ci
nascondiamo ci vergogniamo ci apriamo è
invece con le parole tendiamo a mentire
ora per me questa è una cosa molto
importante perché questo tipo di
comunicazione è quello di cui voglio
parlare che a che fare con la memoria
invece oggi noi siamo coinvolti in una
comunicazione multi tasking come quello
che sta facendo appunto chi sta col
telefonino sta leggendo sta ascoltando
questo questo io lo chiamerei quasi una
sorta di eterno presente non c'è più
passato perché c'è whatsapp c'è facebook
c'è twitter c'è instagram c'è se ci sono
una marea di sollecitazioni che arrivano
da tutte le parti e ci costringono a
rispondere in continuazione altrimenti
turno non esiste altrimenti sei fuori
oggi funziona un po così siamo
continuamente chiamati chiamati a dire
che esisto attraverso l'interazione
l'interazione virtuale sulla rete che
non contempla i cinque sensi e questo è
un problema perché non ci vediamo non ci
ascoltiamo non ci guardiamo non non
annusiamo non gustiamo non tocchiamo
diciamo che nel migliore dei casi il
nostro comunicare online virtuale è un
essere una serie di emoticon buttati
nell'etere va beh ma fino a qui possiamo
dire che ancora c'è una sorta di
comunicazione seppur virtuale
intellettuale ma c'è una comunicazione
il flusso però di di sollecitazione che
riceviamo è talmente continuo che noi
stiamo più dietro e noi siamo andati
oltre per dire che esistiamo non
interagiamo più rispondendo a chi ci
scrive o sollecitando una risposta a
quello cui abbiamo scritto no ci
accontentiamo ormai di affermare noi
stessi la nostra presenza semplicemente
postando foto scrivendo commenti senza
neanche attendere più il feedback di
quell'altro la risposta perché tra
l'altro il rischio è che non arrivi
perché quell'altro impegnato a fare la
stessa cosa
dall'altra parte allora noi affermiamo
disperatamente secondo me la nostra
presenza continuando a postare la
qualunque cosa ho mangiato
dove sono stato poi però c'è la
frontiera estrema di tutto questo
atteggiamento cos'è il self mi faccio il
settimi giro mi faccio illuminare la
sala prenderci di telefoni noemi
fotografo perché se li fotografo e se
appaio dentro la foto allora esisto
altrimenti non esisto facciamo un
esempio se vai in vacanza viene in
salento tutti vogliono venire in salento
la california d'europa a fare la vacanza
bene se tu vieni in vacanza in salento e
non ti fai un self davanti al mare del
salento con qualcosa di riconoscibile
del salento tipo che ne so la torre di
torre dell'orso nella spiaggia di porto
selvaggio o santa per tu in salento non
ci sei stato per tutti i tuoi amici per
tutto il tar e tu non ci sei è stato
esisti solo se sei dentro quella e non
conta più quello che provano i sensi
davanti a quella a quel mare
meraviglioso ai cibi non conta più
perché tu passi il tempo a dichiarare
che esisti fotografando t e fotografando
tutto ciò che fai
inserendo quindi praticamente ti perdi
tutta la vacanza all ora
attenzione che l'ultima frontiera di
questo atteggiamento e fotografarsi uno
con l'altro con il partner mentre si fa
sesso per capire che lo stai facendo
veramente
ecco questo questo lo chiamerei lo
chiamerei un eterno presente quasi mi
verrebbe voglia di cambiare il il motto
cartesiano con buona pace di cartesio
cogito ergo sum in digito ergo sum
questo è il motto della nostra epoca
scusate il guaio il guaio è che in
questo eterno presente appunto non c'è
un passato perché nel momento stesso in
cui scrivo finiscono il flusso e
arrivano già alte sollecitazioni da
altri internauti devo rispondere a
quell'altro e quindi non costruisco
niente che stia prima perché sono sempre
qui nel presente quindi non c'è passato
non c'è niente da ricordare non c'è
niente da cui venire per andare avanti
scusate scusate un attimo scusa no
no sono a un tè dx al lecce non posso
rispondere
grazie scusate è l'eterno presente che
che si presenta il problema però il
problema vero è che il problema vero che
io invece adesso voglio andare avanti
voglio uscire da questo eterno presente
voglio appoggiarmi sul passato per
lavorare il presente e pensare un futuro
voglio ricordare il futuro
e allora faccio un esempio facciamo un
esempio il falegname c'è un falegname
c'è un falegname che ha in mente un
mobile straordinario mobile bellissimo e
un falegname molto fantasioso ha pensato
questo mobile con degli sportelli
intarsiati geometrie perfette cassetti
spazi pieni spazi vuoti legni diversi
che si affiancano uno all'altro stanno
benissimo è una meraviglia questo questo
mobile lo vede davanti a sé talmente e
potente quella visione che non può lo
può quasi toccare sì signore il
falegname ii nella sua bottega davanti a
tutti i pezzi di legno greci a tutti gli
attrezzi che gli servono per realizzare
il mobile
però lì che che cerca di capire da dove
iniziare c'è un problema il falegname
prima di questo di questa idea
meravigliosa di creare questo mobile ha
preso una botta in testa è caduto ha
avuto un piccolo trauma è finito in
ospedale si è svegliato senza tanti
dolori senza nulla i medici hanno detto
che sta bene può tornare a casa va bene
torno a casa ma il guaio è che ha
dimenticato come si usano gli strumenti
non sa più usare gli strumenti per
realizzare il suo mobile adesso però
adesso però non lo so lui ci pensa dice
va bene va bene hannover ci sono tanto
io lo so fare lo so fare lo stesso sono
un falegname ci mette un po di testa e
lo faccio lo stesso va bene prendo un
pezzo di legno cominciò e poi prendo che
cosa prendo il martello prendo yaz
bordino lo scalpello niente non riesce a
ricordare come si usano gli strumenti
per realizzare quel mobile che è
il suo futuro perché sono qui nella sua
mente e nel presente solo qua quando
sarà realizzato il suo futuro ma lui non
sa come uscirne
allora che cosa internet internet va su
google e digita mobile bellissimo
realizzazione e trova una marea di
stimoli una marea di feedback su come si
crea un mobile bellissimo come lo si
realizza ovviamente ognuno dice il
contrario di quell'altro però anche
quando trova delle cose che hanno un
senso per il per il falegname il
problema il problema anche lui appunto
non si ricorda come si usano questi
benedetti attrezzi la sgorbia lo
scalpello la sega il martello la morsa
la raspa la lima tutto non sa le colle
non sa più come come fare allora
allora che fa sbatto la testa sul muro
sbatto la testa sul muro vedrai che
prima o poi mi viene fuori un'idea
comincia a sbattere la testa sul muro
sempre più forte sempre più forte finché
è l'ultima botta forte come quella della
mattina mi fa tornare alla memoria
improvvisamente comincia a vedere a
vedere a ricordare le mani sapienti di
quell'artigiano che lui osservava quando
era bottega faceva il garzone comincia a
vedere come si muovono quale scalpello
prende come usa il martello come si
taglia in legno
stando attenti molto alla venatura del
legno perché se sbagli l'angolo di
taglio il legno si incurva e poi
comincia a pensare a come costruire il
fondo e comincia a realizzarlo perché le
sue mani cominciano di nuovo ad andare
sul ricordo su un ricordo del passato
che gli consente di lavorare nel
presente e pensare il futuro poi vengono
su piano piano le pareti e poi bene la
spalla e poi il la parte superiore del
mobile
adesso mancano soltanto i cassetti
all'interno li mette tutti perfetti
coincidono li fa scorrere neanche un
rumore le sue mani hanno recuperato
tutta la sapienza che viene dal passato
gli consentono di lavorare nel presente
e di pensare il futuro chi è quel mobile
mancano gli sportelli gli sportelli sono
lì con l'intarsio un legno diverso
dall'altro una foglia viene
rappresentata da questi legni tutti i
petali di un fiore intanto vanno messe
le cerniere non è che puoi telefonare a
qualcuno mentre stai lavorando
si scusa come che si fanno gli intarsi e
lì e gli incassi per le cerniere devi
ricordarti lo devi averlo fatto lui le
fa le realizza attacca le cerniere e
metterli sportelli adesso c'è la prova
del nove prendere sportelli di far
chiudere perfetti neanche un rumore gira
la chiave il mobile lì davanti a lui ha
semplicemente ricordato il suo passato
ha lavorato il presente e ha creato il
futuro